so why did Andrew Tate get banned they
did not tell me they did not send me an
email no correspondence I certainly
didn't break terms of service I guess
that's why they couldn't send me an
email and explain why nobody told me
whether it was YouTube that banned me or
meta that banned me they Banned Me
instantly instantly and forever without
any kind of Correspondence they've not
told me why they've not told anyone what
I did
the media machine in synchronization
with the band we can call that
coincidence if you want to believe in
such things came out with some kind of
[ __ ] explanation that I'm
misogynistic or some garbage but the
actual social media companies themselves
provided no explanation at all no
correspondence at all they just deleted
you know what I'm saying are you doing
anything about it are you you know
having your legal team trying to find
out why they did that or you're not
taking any action right now I do have a
lot of things happening behind the
scenes and perhaps I'm becoming
optimistic in my old age but I believe
that in due course the social media
companies will realize the mistake they
made I think that and like I said I
don't have intimate knowledge of the
workings of social media companies but
assuming they are semi-professional to
any regard and that is a big assumption
but let's assume they're professional
that means that when they ban somebody
like me especially the most Google
search person on the planet they must
have teams which are analyzing in real
time the response to set action right
they should have people sitting there on
the ground analyzing now they attacked
me with their media machine because
first they shut you up so they can lie
about you so they shut me up then they
did the massive media push to try and
attempt to lie about me they were
surprised they did the massive media
push calling them a bad person before
they banned him because that happened
like right before where it was all
coming out that he's like an evil
misogynist listen I still it's weird I
still think there's an ulterior motive
there obviously is because they
literally all banned him at the same
time Gmail PayPal well payment
processors it all came like bam well
they all do that they they unify to
control everybody together but I think
they have an ulterior motive besides
just Banning him because if you ban
somebody and you're putting out a PR
push so you're trying to quiet them down
and also get their name in the in the
press it doesn't make sense I think they
probably are going to let him back onto
all the platforms except now they've
made him even bigger so they can make
them make even more money for them
that's what I think I think part of this
Banning [ __ ] is all strategy to just
get people excited about it all yeah
probably yeah
and if these companies have any degree
of professionalism they're analyzing
this in real time and they're
understanding that this makes us look
very bad people didn't believe the lie
people didn't believe what we attempted
to smear this man with nobody is buying
this narrative and this is going to have
a negative effect on us for a very very
long time because when you're in charge
of the world which they are as soon as
you're no longer seen as just and fair
you're seen as tyrannical and once
you're seen as tyrannical then there's
going to be some kind of mass movement
maybe it's just a test to see what
happens if they if they ban one of the
most you know important people or
biggest people on their platform does it
actually affect their does it affect
their bottom line or not I mean there's
an ulterior motive for this besides just
getting rid of dangerous dangerous
players so if I was a social media
executive I would sit and I would
analyze the data and I would say it says
that there's going to be like a big
Uprising from the people that understand
that the social media companies are
unjust but everyone already knows this
and people are so addicted to their
phones and then the biggest competitors
Rumble which they're like no offense
remember your app sucks right now Rumble
genuinely you say that every video
they're getting there I know but it's
just like there's nothing else that even
compares to any of these platforms yeah
you know what I mean so until something
like that comes Nothing's Gonna Change
listen guys we will have a monopoly we
want to retain our Monopoly let's be
smart here being known as tyrannical
amongst the public Consciousness across
the entire planet it's gonna make it
very difficult for us to hold our
Monopoly for longer period of time as
opposed to being seen to be fair even if
we're biased we must be seen as Fair
sure as soon as we're seen as tyrannical
that's when the revolution look at ciao
chesku as soon as you're as soon as
you're Tyrant that's when everyone hits
the streets yep so I think that if they
have any kind of serious data monitoring
and if they have any kind of serious
business professionalism they are now
talking in dark rooms understanding that
this has played out very badly for them
and if they intend on keeping their
Monopoly into the future that they need
to change something
maybe I'm being optimistic who was the
first one to take you off Meta Meta was
first Facebook Instagram Facebook
Instagram okay well then it was a domino
effect yeah so Mada took me down so it's
quite interesting actually I had a
YouTube channel for a while it was never
so large I had 738 000 subscribers it
took me a long time to build it up I got
a strike on YouTube which prevented me
from posting
it's got a strike no big deal the next
day
met up took me down deleted my Facebook
and my Instagram
um the Press came out at exactly the
same time in sync saying that I'm a
misogynistic dangerous person that I'm
harmful that I am the reason that the
world is not a perfect place world
hunger you name it all my fault
attacked me across all of this and I
thought okay let me film a message that
I can get out on my YouTube my final
message which I don't know if you guys
have seen I ended up putting on
freetopg.com
let me film my final message explaining
how this is unfair and unjust we filmed
it we produced it we got it all at a
within 12 hours had to tell ready to go
but we couldn't post it because the
YouTube stripe so we're waiting for the
YouTube strike to expire a few hours
before the YouTube strike expires guess
what happens they Banned Me from YouTube
then they Banned Me from Discord
then they banned me for Airbnb
they Banned Me from stripe
Airbnb was the funniest one like we
don't want you using that [ __ ]
airbnbs anymore like what does that do
man I can't even remember
you could believe breaking rules
oh no no the Matrix presses a button my
friend and every app on your phone stops
working Uber
there's somebody at every company that's
probably assigned to this panel of kind
of like that truths are or the morality
their morality is ours at each at each
one of these companies and they just sit
there all day and and decide when it's
big enough that we all have to
coordinate so and ruin this person I
think they did to Donald Trump there's
like a couple of options it's either
like all the the top people coordinate
and they recognize that this guy's
dangerous or there's some entity above
all of those those companies that tells
them what they have to do and they're
like nope this guy's cut off from
everything Banning them from Uber that's
the stupidest [ __ ] I've ever heard what
are you what are you gonna do did you
not just think he'd make a new account
because what is he going to go through
an Uber and like Snap Snap the driver's
neck he probably has a personal driver
like he goes don't even want to use Uber
UK based Banks as well
I can name Santander HSBC Barclays Etc
all at the same time oh no sorry the
change we've decided because blah blah
some [ __ ] some let her close your
accounts so they take all your banking
they take your payment processing take
all your social media presence they take
your Discord they take your Skype they
take all your accounts your ability to
communicate with people and then they
lie about you in the Press
and that and they leave you there they
leave you there to suffer
you can understand the social component
all right these guys are probably
working in unison yeah when you hear
payment processors Banks apps like uber
how are you processing that no I mean
that's why he has to do something about
it because you know for me there's
plenty of great lawyers did you hear
about what happened with Alex brenneson
lately
Ericson Alex yeah
I heard he sued Twitter or something
Twitter did you follow the story I don't
know I don't know the exact story no so
he was on Joe Rogan if you've not seen
it I highly recommend you watch this so
he is saying things about Twitter matter
of fact the tweets that got him in
trouble got him his fifth strike was the
following tweet we can put put this up
there because I'm just reading what he
said this is a tweet he put out that he
said it doesn't stop infection or
transmission don't think of it as a
vaccine think of it as at best a
therapeutic with a limited window of
efficacy and terrible side effects
profile that must be dosed in advance of
illness and we want to mandate it
Insanity that's a sweep so he gets
banned makes a lot of sense to me in
December of last year which was six
months after when Biden said wait what
was that anybody who allows debates of
vaccine I listened to the um The Joe
Rogan podcast with him insane in any I
highly recommend anyone here check that
out it's not after when Biden said
anybody who allows debates of vaccine
should be banned or shouldn't be allowed
meaning there shouldn't be anything
that the president of the United States
that says that uh debate should be
banned debt whoever is is having this
debate on the side that he doesn't he
doesn't want them to should be banned
that open discourse is you know it isn't
okay here in America when a lot of the
centers okay the censorship about the
vaccine and stuff became a lot more
serious is when Biden came out and he
was saying that anyone who spreads
anything wrong or bad about the vaccine
then it's misinformation and it's bad
and right after that all these fact
Checkers popped up and that's when
people started getting banned and you
couldn't even you couldn't even talk
about the vaccine without getting your
platform wiped off but how about right
when the vaccine was being developed you
know Kamala Harris and so many leftists
with big platforms from entertainers to
hey thanks Sean from entertainers to
politicians to elected officials we're
saying I will never take Trump's vaccine
ever and then right down the road
they're shoving it down our throats and
mandating it and firing people why do
you think the transportation system and
shipping and supplies are all screwed up
around the world because they tried to
mandate it and a lot of people said you
know what shove it I'm out California is
believe it or not a very big freedom
speech please because they allow
protesting a judge that was appointed by
Bill Clinton comes in and says I'm
allowing this to go through because
typically section 230 that is in place
in 1998 was to protect social media
sites and many of these online sites
that if you offend your ex-wife or if
you offend your brother it has nothing
to do with Facebook so they kind of
protected themselves but Alex was able
to go all the way because of his court
judge that was appointed by Clinton not
not Obama or Trump but by Clinton he
goes in eventually he says you get to um
have two people uh from Twitter to come
to court to defend themselves so he
could have gone to Jack Dorsey long
story short they finally lifted it he is
on uh Twitter and he's posting heavily
talking about the fact the reason why he
got banned is because the government
didn't want him on inciting what she
what he was inciting so another pure
example where there's literally the hard
paper evidence that the government came
in and told them to ban him it's there's
evidence of it in in this legality issue
it's insane and uh I don't want to say
too much on the podcast but legal
options are certainly being explored
we'll see how things progress across the
next few few weeks but I have a very
strong suspicion I will end up back on
the media platforms and or they will
offer them back to me the question now
at this point is if I even want them
which is a unique question because a lot
of people still believe that you can
only have a significant presence in the
world with these social media platforms
that's the source of their power I
believe there's huge pressure behind the
dam in regards to the fact that
everybody understands that these places
are tyrannical and that they control
ideas and that they force narratives and
I use my wording as the Matrix I call
them the Matrix and people say me why do
you calling the Matrix and I say because
they project a false version of reality
in real time that people subscribe to if
there wasn't an absolute Blacklist on
all opposing views during covet 19. that
[ __ ] would never have gone on for as
long as it did it went on for as long as
it did and they managed to purport a
false version of reality for so long
because you couldn't discuss the
opposing side yeah we just talked about
our friend here on the kitchen table
that was it or and we we risked losing
our jobs we risked losing our family and
friends you know especially people that
work for the city or the state or the
federal government they just had to zip
up and if they had an opinion is speak
speak to it at home in private only I I
want to kind of get your thoughts on
something that he said before he got
back into covet there that he said a lot
of people think that you know he doesn't
he doesn't know if he wants to be back
on on these platforms and he says a lot
of people think that that's the only way
to get your voice out but unless there's
a massive cultural shift on this planet
how are people really going to get out
there without these things in the short
in the short term future I I'm curious
if anybody has any any thoughts on this
because this is the first time you
really can't think about even the reason
that Tate is still staying relevant is
because of these platforms it's just
that he doesn't have his own platform
it's other people posting his stuff you
know right so even if he doesn't go back
Tate is still going to be on these
platforms unless they just wipe his face
off of the off of it and then if they
wipe his face off of it everyone's just
gonna go to whatever other platform but
Tate aside right he's saying he's
talking about a bigger idea of how
people think that this is the only way
to have a platform and right now it
really is it is the mainstream form of
you know platform for communication the
way radio it was in the in the 20s when
people just sit around the radio and
hear and then the television came out
and so on and so on uh back before that
when the printing press came out and
newspapers became that this is the
mainstream way now what other way is
there I like I said first time thinking
about it I can't see another way I am
really curious uh what if he's gonna
finish that thought and get on that
because what are you gonna do like fly
over like in World War II and drop
leaflets with your thoughts on them
we'll just go to a different platform
it's the big thing that's what he's
doing right now with Rumble everything
and then he goes there it's not there's
Rumble channels like already bigger than
his YouTube it's gonna be a while before
that is truly effective enough a lot of
people who are on YouTube may not
necessarily agree with everything he
says but they don't hate them and they
might give them a shot but those same
people may have liberal views and look
at Rumble as some right-wing lunatic
social media platform which it's not
it's just a free speech run and so
people who like free speech go there
people who aren't worried about getting
their feelings hurt go there so it's it
really is it really they do have a
tremendous scary amount of power so when
you get huge media companies that can
literally alter in reality in real time
by deleting the other side of an
argument they're creating a matrix is
what I like to call it so I call them
the source of the Matrix so people
understand this and there's huge
pressure behind the dam but the problem
is people say well what's the
alternative and I think if someone could
pave the way and put a crack in the dam
by maintaining massive relevancy despite
of a ban and still having a social media
platform and presence which is respected
on other other platforms I think it's
going to do them significant damage I
think the pressure and the crack
together is going to create something so
that's his that's his answer exactly
what you said just other platforms it's
crazy because even when I like reached
out to Tate and um he respond I told him
about when YouTube like struck down half
of my videos and I reached out to him
and he told me like his suggestion is to
move to rumble but keep like promoting
your content on these other platforms
because like at the end of the day there
just isn't a way for you to to get big
right now and that's why even as much as
like I'm not happy about having to stay
on YouTube like I wish there was a free
speech platform where I wasn't worried
about it so it's what you have to do
there's not there's no alternative you
know at the moment nobody throwing a
rumble I only had 738
000 subscribers on my YouTube after five
years of work post band I moved to
rumble which is a YouTube competitor
stock price has gone up 36 and I'm at
five I'm at half a million subscribers
in two weeks so I'm about to surpass the
size of my YouTube channel within a
month
um YouTube stocks down Rumble stocks
massively up so all in all there's
there's there's there's there's other
avenues but we'll see I I have a I
certainly agree with you that what
they've done to me is massively unfair
they know it's unfair I think the reason
they didn't send me an email or any
confirmation of what I did wrong is
because they knew they would end up in
court and they didn't want to be tied
down to their reason they want to stay
fluid and try to make up a reason on the
day uh I've heard from very reliable
sources that their terms of service have
changed significantly post my band
they've made up new reasons post span
they've made a bunch of new [ __ ] so it's
going to be interesting but certainly
yeah there has to be legal ramifications
for what they've done I don't take it
personally but I do take it
professionally and you're right they
were wrong I have no reason to be banned
my Instagram is Just Cars it's just cars
and and a little bit of flexing there's
no politics poetry there's not even any
points of view I had no strikes legit
posts
if they were betting odds like if we did
a poll why do you think Andrew Tate was
banned from all the social media
platforms and it was
misogyny right you know coveted stuff
against the governments against system
if you were a betting man where would
you kind of place the odds oh I already
know everybody already knows I was
banned because I talked against against
the Matrix you know the system in
general the system in general yeah I
mean someone compared me to
Socrates which is a compliment but he
was vilified he ended up poisoning
himself in Athens and the charge against
him was corrupting the youth if you read
about his poisoning and his arrest they
said he was corrupting the youth but he
wasn't corrupting them he was inspiring
them to challenge authority it's
inspiring them to think for themselves
when they were told something instead of
blindly complying he said look analyze
who these people are who are telling you
to do eggs and I even had a tweet I put
out
on my I mean I've been banned on Twitter
forever so because I've been through 20
Twitter bands I come back as undercover
whatever but I I've been saying for all
I said often I said if you have a if you
have a point of view that you are very
strong in your adherence to if you truly
believe something you need to sit and
analyze whether it's your own personal
experience it makes you believe
something or something someone else or
something else is convinced you of this
and if they have you need to then once
again analyze that point of view and
analyze who this who these people are
and what they want from you do they
truly want the best of you if the news
convinces you of something to the point
where you're gonna argue with your only
own family members at dinner table does
the news really care about you more than
your family this is a genuine question
you need to analyze every belief you
hold where it came from and then analyze
what their intentions are wow in a video
a few videos ago before I even heard him
say that I said the same exact thing
that every single thing that you hear
from Media or online that there's an
agenda behind it and that my agenda for
making YouTube videos and stuff is to
build up a following monetize it start
my University to teach people I
literally just said this my agenda isn't
malintentioned you know you you got you
can't sit behind me when the camera's
over here kid because if I gotta talk to
you then they're seeing the back of my
head you know what I'm saying oh look at
something like kobit for example it's an
easy one you look at all the [ __ ]
they were saying and you sit here no
wait wait these people don't care about
me
or my cancer all right if I got in a car
crash
medical bills I could never possibly
afford they'd let me die but they are
insisting I take this Shaw for free on
repeat this doesn't make sense and when
you and when you encourage people to
think for themselves especially the
youth that's what Socrates got accused
of he's corrupting the youth
and and to be honest with you a huge
portion of my fan base were 18 to 23 24
year old males when you have the youth
the masculine Youth of the world
thinking for themselves that's pretty
scary to Authority because it's the
masculine Youth of the world that is one
the revolutionaries and two also that's
the backbone of the slave Force if you
need people to go die in a ditch in
Afghanistan you need them you need
people to work [ __ ] jobs in a coal
mine with no Health Care you need them
if you need people to blindly comply to
[ __ ] you need them more than anybody
more than you need the feminists and not
[ __ ] the Liberals you need the real
men to go out there and comply with the
[ __ ] to live a shitty existence to
purport and prop up a system the warrior
the warrior class right and if enough of
these men stand in one place and say
this is enough that's when a revolution
happens so this is the most dangerous
group of the demographic that the Matrix
and the people are trying to control and
they have to have a narrative over and
that's why they're trying to weaken them
in every regard and when I'm sitting
there saying don't listen to the
[ __ ] become physically strong think
for yourself prioritize your Brotherhood
above what the [ __ ] Matrix is telling
you do not blindly comply you know
resist the slave mind all these things
I'm saying they just sat there one day
and said wait even simpletons can can
get these basic uh tenants and and
accept these basic philosophies of you
know align yourself with the best
possible people you can and take care of
yourself physically have physical
strength learn as much as you can that
you are capable of most human beings are
not going to be a chess master like his
father was it's not going to happen they
don't have the intellect for that and
that's fine but we can all reach to the
our own personal best on a daily basis
and even simpletons can do that and if
he got that deep into the Matrix so he
could pull out those people could you
even imagine how powerful the people of
the world would be and and how scary
that would be for the few that are in
power controlling it's horrible for them
it makes total sense that they abandoned
it makes it completely against what they
what they need to get out there
my God
I got a big [ __ ] crack in the first
shot I'd rather riding on the wall won't
last long yeah